questo format è famoso per due cose la
prima il microonde lui il nostro vecchio
compagno di viaggio salvatore carnefice
delle nostre vite
la seconda è la carbonara che abbiamo
mangiato in tutti i modi francese
italiana abbia fatto tra carbonare oggi
uniremo le due cose la carbonara e il
microonde facendo un microonde alla
carbonara
partiamo subito col video ciao ragazzi
bentornati in una puntata di cucina
buttata un po di giorni fa siamo
incappati in un video che ci ha fatto
letteralmente accapponare la pelle di un
tizio che non citerò perché non voglio
favorire odio nei suoi confronti ecco
credo però che sia giusto per motivi
scientifici comprendere effettivamente
se quello che sta avvenendo fatto che
agli occhi di dio è peccato puro non si
sa è tutto sommato un qualcosa di
vagamente buono è commestibile
quindi partiamo subito con gli
ingredienti della carbonara al microonde
io oppure fanno quindi secondo me
partiamo anche da degli ottimi
quanto ci vorrà prima pochissimo calcola
che eri un piatto magari corsia sul
fuoco sì sì molto meno e molto dello
stesso molto meno anche quello pasta
pancetta
ma partiamo con la pancetta e non col
guanciale in qualche posto magnifico
insieme a harry potter e gli unicorni
addirittura pecorino mi fa schifo
raga come cacchio fate a mangiarlo
inutili a suo dire mourinho sì perché si
mischia ma così da solo vuol vederla di
nuovo la mia reazione non si dice che
schifo del cibo ma diventato io
crescendo mi sono cambiati i gusti
quindi un sacco di formaggio riesco a
mangiare ma ancora e passate nella pasta
preferita e cacio e pepe perché sciolto
e è diverso ho capito dire comunque
avanti
abbiamo bisogno di un uomo pepe e poi in
realtà qui non lo scrive ma anche a sale
ragazzino tra le serie banditi
dall'inquadratura un quadro le
inquadrare inquadrare spielberg facci
vedere
ricordiamo che enrico è colui che fa
venire il vomito tutte quante le persone
che guardano i video che ogni volta
cerco di capire che cosa succede
all'interno del riflessione all'interno
di the blair witch project 15 scusami se
non ti ha aiutato molto abilmente se
incomincia a fare così la ripresa e
parla di german ditte prima cosa che
dobbiamo fare separare il tuorlo
dall'album e questo è un procedimento
abbastanza italiano ma quello dei
gestori del tipologia come come di tutta
la finale non possiamo dirlo
non ce la sentiamo ecco di fare questo
qui alle quel sole che guardano ammesso
un solo uovo non ho capito a dieta la
pasta non è nemmeno tanta quanto saranno
manco a 100 grammi dieta per quanto mi
riguarda se facendo delle tubature
bellissime fermissime c'è un terremoto
quindi sembra cooking mama ma cooking
mama cattiva cooking non ma non posso
fare la porta ma come faccia smart e me
lo stai facendo apposta è una miseria
per quanto mi riguarda ma noi seguiamo
la ricetta e dell e si tratta di degrado
totale tutti i tutorial paro paro paro
quando si tratta di farle bene è vero a
questo punto prendiamo un piatto
mettiamo la carta assorbente sopra e
disponiamo la pancetta sbaglio è
rientrata una noi vi prego ma si può
mangiavano c'entra cruda macineranno di
noi ragazzi
non ve lo mettiamo sopra che c'è sopra
un altro tovagliolo assorbe il grasso
quindi evita che sia molli al messia
mollino zoe verrà un invertebrato lo
scopriremo a brevissimo perché lui fa
questa specie di panino di coccio così
56 minuti
a cosa tra concorrenti precog alla
nostra piccola cassandra come comodo
cucinare fianco a fianco e crudo e
crudele
io ti sei bruciato targa
quanta cottura o che cotto il tuo maiolo
e coltissimo ok no a sto punto uniamo
sta a me ma mi chiedo ma perché per
stranieri per me io mi chiedo ma perché
punto questo qui è il nostro lecca lecca
tabella aggiunge il peso non emette
tantissimo non ne metteremo un po di più
perché c'è tanto sapore da coprire
ho bisogno di un minuto
torna su più di sei ufficiali the
all'inferno ma vi rendete conto che
questo qui ha fatto quello che ho appena
fatto io vi aspettate e poi fa e ora
continuiamo a scavare aggiungiamo del
sale e dell'acqua questo è il tuo sogno
di fargli italia voleri al microonde
giuseppe che c'è il mio legale che ti
contatterà tre minuti al massimo
scusatemi ragazzi non ho potuto fare
altrimenti addio ma si allontano
veramente la poi cosi e la quadra
è il caso che raccontano bene
e allora migliori amici e molto
paranormale questa riduzione insieme qui
dentro non c'è spezzata
no impossibile che sia cotta in tre
minuti ma dobbiamo togliere il coperchio
e continuare a cucinare per altri otto
minuti prima a fare piatto di pasta 8
minuti c'è ora ci andavo più bella fa
dopo
mio dio
migliorano con la faccia io la trovo
deliziosa no e ancora tra pendente dal
santone 1 cm europea
complimenti come la dentista con ragazzi
lo sfondo che cambierà secondo un'altra
cosa che diventa le manca un po di sale
la cultura cioè rottura pulsanti tre
minuti ma guardate come fai ancora prima
a cuocere sei chili di polemiche no no
non sto facendo pulire no
no però poi lui aggiunge l'acqua di
cottura mi sembra d'aver visto
aggiungere che avevo come fatto nella
vita
basta basta mamma mia ragazzi sono
veramente delle risse della scotta a
questo punto lui con tutto l'entusiasmo
del creato aggiunge la pasta si riesce
nemmeno attraverso per momento orribile
oscena se poteva aggiungere un altro
uomo radicato icose cacata e venite qui
vicino a me siete così tre sedute allora
se ci sediamo detto in due sulla è stata
stop cioè che volessi dire però ci siamo
informati su una meta e riposano nel
mezzo si raffredda e si rovina
allora adattata kampala gamba la gamba
turno
allora ragazzi prima ancora prima di
iniziare l'assaggio vi ricordo che se mi
è piaciuto questo video mi è piaciuto
questo video iscrivetevi a questo canale
e mettete naturalmente un pollice in su
si ha sete piaciuto che se pure si
ballerà stasera da seguire
pensiamo alle regioni veramente ti piace
ti piace bracco si si capiscono quando
dici orribile era peggio la francese
ragazzi che ci vediamo la prossima
domenica sempre alle 12 con una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata ciao ciao ciao
la cultura e la passano nemmeno male io
pure pensavo peggio
ma questa un qualcosa morale della
favola provati ci vorrà la tavola
ragazzi a provare per giudicare sempre
con questa massima ma non a me